hola hello we are Martin Jo
we're from Patagonia in Argentina
tarimov Australis we want to discover
the beautiful state of Brandenburg and
its countryside Lavinia aliamanu won't
you join us
let's go
there are so many trees so much greenery
this is really a pleasure for us it's
like a gift given to us by the earth for
us to enjoy participa
quantify these villages have so much
restante
and history you see it especially in the
monuments like this castle a mosquito we
wanted to get to know the small rural
towns because that's where you get a
true sense of the culture if not in the
big cities
these small towns are charming such
peace and quiet
what is a beautiful lake I'll take a few
pictures good the Elaine Strasser the
German Avenue Road offers a chance to
explore the country of the main highways
you discover places like this beautiful
so much nature it makes us so happy he
gives us so much joy
mock Joe how lovely look at the stones
so interesting the way they were put
between the bricks how amazing to see a
church like this in a village in the
middle of the countryside
I think really it's incredible
sculptures like this in such a small
church they belong in one of the big
grand Cathedral they're very beautiful
very like a Tyrell is not important
education is more Bonita
smells delicious
we'll say goodbye to you here in this
lovely place before we continue on our
journey we suggest you come and spend a
little time here yourselves like a
Brandenburg's great